Joss Whedon's Firefly was poised to be
the next huge sci-fi series to change
television unfortunately those hopes
were dashed after one incomplete season
let's look back at the reasons why
fireflies lights went out
a small loyal fan base like Joss
Whedon's other shows Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and angel Firefly developed a
strong dedicated fan base
unfortunately the fans weren't in great
enough numbers to halt cancellation
despite letter-writing campaigns to keep
it alive still the show's abrupt ending
shouldn't be surprising considering what
happened before it even began production
marriage trouble according to Business
Insider Fox's bigwigs had a problem with
two of the characters Zoey and wash
being happily married Fox told Whedon to
nix their marriage or they'd mix the
deal Whedon revealed in the Firefly DVD
commentary that he stuck to his guns
saying then don't pick up the show
because in my show these people are
married ultimately the execs back down
and the show made it to the airwaves but
that didn't mean the troubles ended
Friday night fright Firefly was
scheduled for Friday nights better known
among TV fans as the quote Friday night
death slot now airing on Friday nights
doesn't automatically predestined shows
for early cancellation unless that show
airs on Fox at over 30 television series
foxes actually canceled more Friday
night programs than any other network
Firefly had a death sentence right out
of the gate the episodes aired out of
order when Whedon conceived the show he
planned it as an episodic yet continuous
story divided into hour-long chunks the
episodes needed to air in a specific
order to make sense to viewers somehow
this went over Fox execs his head's a
needs chapter of Firefly aired out of
order on Fox the pilot which introduces
the characters and plot of the entire
venture didn't air until the end of the
show's run the promos didn't capture the
spirit of the show Fox's adds promos and
commercials for Firefly failed to
properly convey what the show is about
or what it was in spirit as producer
Chris Buchanan said on the DVD
commentary the campaign suggested
Firefly was a wacky genre comedy when it
wasn't and as author Amy Pascal wrote
and Joss Whedon the biography viewers
who would have loved the show with two
alienated to watch it and those
tuned in because the promos were
disappointed low ratings with everything
going against it
fireflies bad ratings were unsurprising
on average that attracted about 4.7
million viewers while that's a huge
number in and of itself it's puny by
Network television standards according
to E online Firefly finished at 98th
place in the Nielsen ratings the show
itself was excellent but Fox only cared
about numbers an executive defense
despite all the obstacles they placed
before the show success the folks at Fox
essentially played dumb when it came to
fireflies cancellation former Fox
Entertainment president Gail Berman told
the Pittsburgh post-gazette
having to cancel it was very difficult
must have been difficult considering she
was part of the decision-making process
that led the series episodes airing out
of order and on Friday nights at least
fans eventually got some closure in the
form of 2005 serenity the big motion
picture follow-up to the series that's
better than some one season wonders ever
get thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos at
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know what you think we
lost Firefly too early